-Pro-Trump
January 6th conspirator
Jim Jordan
lost a second bid
to become
the Speaker of the House today,
receiving even fewer votes
than he got
on the first ballot yesterday,
leaving Republicans
in total chaos
and no closer
to resolving their crisis
than they were
two weeks ago.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
We're now going on two weeks
without a Speaker of the House,
meaning one of our two chambers
of Congress
is completely paralyzed
and can't do anything.
Jordan lost one ballot yesterday
and then another today.
In fact,
after today's failed ballot,
the temporary Speaker,
Patrick McHenry,
immediately gaveled the House
back into recess.
-Pursuant to clause 12(a)
of Rule I,
the chair declares
the House in recess,
subject to the call
of the chair.
-"We took one vote
and [bleep] it up.
I'd say let's call it a day."
It's like if the first kid
in a Little League game
struck out
and the coach said,
"Ah, hell with this
same old [bleep]
We forfeit!
"Tyler's our best hitter!
If he strikes out,
we're [bleep]"
Although McHenry seems to have
gotten a note
to tone down his gavel bang,
compared to two weeks ago
when he was so mad
he nearly broke the dais.
[ Gavel bangs ]
[ Laughter ]
Is he gaveling the House
into recess,
or did he just see a
New York City bathtub cockroach?
You know the kind --
they just sort of dance
around the edge of the drain
as if to say, "That's right.
I live here all the time."
McHenry's gavel is the sound
the coyote makes
whenever he falls off a cliff.
-Meep-meep!
[ High-pitched whistling ]
[ Gavel bangs ]
[ Laughter ]
-So, the House still
has no Speaker.
And for all the Republican
complaints about Biden --
he's too old, he's too woke,
he's too weak --
even they have to admit,
he's a sentient being
who exists.
And the Republicans
can't even deliver that,
which at the very least,
gives us a chance to update
our ongoing montage
of House Republican chaos.
And while we do that,
I'm gonna take a few sips
from this bottle of whiskey.
-Kevin McCarthy practically
daring hardline Republicans
to come after him.
-If somebody wants to make
a motion against me, bring it.
-To which Gaetz responded,
"Just did."
-He says he's coming for you.
Can you survive?
-Yes. I'll survive.
-The Speaker of the House has
been removed from his position.
-Some House Republicans
have been in contact with
and have started an effort
to draft former
President Donald Trump
to be the next Speaker.
-Donald Trump has
just endorsed Jim Jordan
to be the next
Speaker of the House.
-On Capitol Hill right now,
we have breaking news.
House Republicans have nominated
Steve Scalise
moments ago
as their new Speaker.
-I want to thank my House
Republican colleagues
for just designating me
as the Speaker.
-Just hours after
being nominated to become
the next Speaker
of the House,
Congressman Steve Scalise says
he's dropping out of the race.
-I'm withdrawing my name
as a candidate
for the Speaker designee.
-Jim Jordan is the new
Republican nominee for Speaker.
-Jim Jordan is trying
to rally support
ahead of a planned vote today.
-My prediction is
Jim will win this,
and even on the first
round of votes.
-Congressman Jim Jordan lost
the first vote
for House Speaker.
-A Speaker has not been elected.
-Jim Jordan plans to take
his second shot
at the speakership
on the House floor.
-Congressman Jim Jordan
appears to have lost
the second round
of votes for Speaker.
-A Speaker has not been elected.
-You probably thought
this bottle would be empty
after that long montage.
Well, it's not.
Because this is
the second bottle.
[ Laughter ]
So, the House still
has no Speaker.
In fact, Jordan actually
lost more votes
on today's ballot
than he did on yesterday's.
As evidence of how bad
it's getting,
one GOP member of Congress voted
for a former Republican Speaker
who has been extremely vocal
about how much he hated the job.
-We really are sort of in
silly season with some of this.
Congressman Mike Kelly voted
for former Speaker Boehner.
-If John Boehner
found out someone
was trying
to make him Speaker again,
he would immediately
burst into tears.
Remember that? Boehner crying?
'Cause that was a thing.
And that's today's topical
reference from 10 years ago.
[ Laughter ]
Besides, Boehner --
and this is true --
is super into weed now.
He became a cannabis
entrepreneur after he retired.
That's how long the [bleep] show
in the House Republican
Conference
has been going on.
That was so long ago
that when we did a piece
on Boehner resigning,
I looked like this.
If you were to compare
how Boehner looks now
to how I look now,
you would definitely assume
I was the one
who got super into weed.
No more suits, man.
I'm wearing a cardigan
and growing my hair out
to look like The Dude.
[ Laughter ]
So, Jordan lost a second,
humiliating vote,
and we're going on two weeks
without a functioning
House of Representatives,
and everyone is pissed about it.
Especially Republicans, who keep
admitting that this spectacle
is making them look like
a bunch of incompetent morons.
-Funding the government
is part of our fundamental duty,
and we can't even do that.
It's bordering
on the -- on the absurd.
-This is petty.
-This is not responsible.
-Makes us look like
a bunch of idiots.
-We keep playing those clips
because they're the ones
saying all the stuff
we usually say about them.
They're doing their own
"Closer Look" about themselves.
Soon, Rudy Giuliani
is gonna go on Fox News
and say, "You know what
I just realized?
I look like I sat on my balls."
[ Laughter ]
Seriously, Republicans are
making all of our points for us.
At this point, we don't even
need to do any writing.
Wally's cue cards
are all blank.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, Wally, sometimes you have
lines on the show, right?
-Yeah, that's right.
-And when you do,
one of the other cue card guys
holds your cue cards?
-That's correct.
-But the other day,
you had the line,
"Well, Seth,"
before I cut you off.
And I'm just wondering,
do you have cue cards
when your line is that short?
-No, no, I just remember it.
-Yeah, that makes sense.
Republicans are --
So you can memorize a line
that short?
-Sure.
-Because when the editors
were looking
at Monday's "Closer Look,"
they noticed something
was written on your hand.
And when they zoomed in,
they saw this.
[ Laughter ]
So...
-Yeah, that was
for something else.
-That was for something else?
-Yeah.
I always write little notes
on my hand.
Want to see mine today?
-Yeah, sure.
[ Laughter ]
Alright.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, good.
And it's not just
Republican politicians.
Conservative pundits
are also mad at them.
Not mad at them for nominating
an election denier
and coup plotter
like Jim Jordan, mind you,
but for not
lining up behind him.
Fox host Brian Kilmeade
was caught on a hot mic
during yesterday's vote,
insulting one member of Congress
who chose not to vote
for Jim Jordan.
Kilmeade's not on screen,
so listen for his comment
at the end.
-Bacon.
-McCarthy.
-Dumbass.
[ Laughter ]
-Even worse, he had to write
that line on his hand.
[ Laughter ]
Do you know how bad
things are for you
when Brian Kilmeade
is calling you a dumbass?
This is a guy so dumb,
he once tried to roast
a marshmallow over an open flame
with a plastic spoon.
-I got the marshmallows.
-Alright, while Steve roasts
his marshmallows...
Watch. Watch your fingers.
-That's a little dangerous.
-They're small.
They're a little small.
Can we get a stick?
Anybody got a stick?
[ Indistinct chatter ]
Ouch! That's hot.
Ouch!
-You're really gonna do that
with your hands?
You're not gonna...?
-Yeah, you're right.
Upon further review,
we're looking for a stick.
-Oh, plastic!
-No, no, no! Not plastic!
That's bad for the environment.
[ Laughter ]
-So, Steve Doocy tried
to use his hand
to roast
a cocoa-sized marshmallow.
Then Kilmeade said,
"No, I've got a better idea.
How about plastic?"
We have an annual fire safety
training here at 30 Rock,
and never once has the
fire marshal thought to tell us,
"Don't stick a plastic spoon
into an open flame."
Meanwhile, the fire marshal
at Fox & Friends
has to clarify that
when you use the fire escape,
you want to make sure
you go down.
[ Laughter ]
By the way, just to give you
an idea of how much worse
Fox News has gotten
in the 13 years since that clip,
the only two people in that clip
still employed by the network
are the guys who tried to roast
a marshmallow
with their hands
and a plastic spoon.
But the role of Fox News here
goes beyond muttered insults,
because it turns out some of
the right-wing personalities
have been pressuring
Republican holdouts
to back Jordan,
including Sean Hannity.
And now that pressure campaign
seems to have backfired,
making Republicans even angrier.
On his radio show this week,
Hannity took exception
to the allegation
that he was trying to influence
Republicans to back Jordan.
-Yeah.
He's like the entire newspaper.
You should see his funny pages.
[ Laughter ]
So, why are conservative
hardliners
pressuring everyone
to vote for Jordan?
Because Trump backs Jordan
and Jordan backs Trump.
Jordan was a key player
in the January 6th coup attempt
and still to this day
refuses to say
that the 2020 election
was not stolen.
He was named throughout
the congressional report
on the insurrection
as a key player,
defied a subpoena
to answer questions,
and was listed on
the president's call sheet
from that day.
According to a copy obtained
by The Washington Post,
the schedule says
that at 9:24 a.m.,
the President talked
with Representative Jim Jordan.
But Jordan initially refused
to answer questions
about whether he spoke
with Trump on January 6th,
leading to this very awkward
interview with a reporter.
-Yes or no?
Did you speak with
President Trump on January 6th?
-Yeah, I mean, I speak-- I spoke
with the president last week.
I speak with the president
all the time.
I spoke with him
on January 6th.
I mean, I talk with
President Trump all the time.
Uh, I-I-I'm actually
kind of amazed
sometimes that people
keep asking this que--
Of course, I talk with
the president all the time.
I talk with him -- Like I said,
I talked with him last week.
-On January 6th,
did you speak with him before,
during, or after
the Capitol was attacked?
-Uh, I'd have to go...
I-I-I...
I spoke with him
that day...after?
I think after.
I don't know if I spoke with him
in the morning or not.
I-I just don't know.
Uh, I'd have to go back and...
I-I mean, I don't -- I don't --
I don't know, uh, th-that,
w-when -- when those
conversations happened.
-When someone talks that fast,
they're either holding
an auction, lying their ass off,
or pitching a screenplay
at a Malibu beach house
after snorting
a mountain of blow.
By the way, congrats
to that reporter for remaining
completely still and just
letting Jordan spin out.
That's how you do it.
Just sit there motionless while
he picks up speed
like a bull[bleep] bobsledder.
[ Laughter ]
Jordan was talking so fast,
the only way you could
slow him down
is if one of his fellow
Republicans
knocked him over the head
like this.
[ Gavel bangs ]
[ Laughter ]
Trump and his allies
want Jordan in charge
so they can take another crack
at what they tried
and failed to do on January 6th.
The other problem is,
no one sane wants to be Speaker
because it's a horrible job
where you have to deal
with lunatics like Jim Jordan --
leaving an opening for lunatics
like Jim Jordan.
In fact, here's
how much the job
of being a Republican
Speaker of the House sucks.
One GOP congressman,
Ken Buck,
who has simply asked
that any future Speaker
admit Biden fairly won
the election,
joked on CNN that he voted
for someone
he knows for a fact
wouldn't want the job.
-Joining me now
is Republican Congressman
Ken Buck of Colorado.
He did not vote
for Congressman Jim Jordan,
instead voting
for Tom Emmer.
Well, I guess
my first question is,
do you really want Tom Emmer
to be Speaker?
-No, I don't.
I don't like Tom Emmer.
I figured this would be
the worst job in America.
-Okay, so just
to underscore that,
you voted for somebody
because you don't like them.
-I-I voted for somebody
'cause I wasn't gonna vote
for Jim Jordan.
-Yeah, but -- but you don't...
It's not because you want him
to be Speaker.
Okay, well, that says a lot
about where we are right now.
[ Laughter ]
-He voted for someone
who doesn't want to be Speaker
because the job
of Speaker sucks.
It's third in line
to the presidency,
and Republicans are treating it
like it's a punishment
on "Impractical Jokers."
And at this point, why not?
Give the gavel to Murr and let
the other jokers tell him
what to do with it
through an earpiece
while they watch
from inside a van.
"Bang it so hard
you break the podium."
The fundamental problem here
is that
the GOP is
a fractured coalition
with no discernible
ideological core,
except that most of them want
to dismantle American democracy.
And on top of that, the job
of Speaker absolutely sucks.
In order to want it, you'd have
to be a...
-Petty...
-Absurd...
-Dumbass.
-This has been
"A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]